so if i could let me um
read our script and then we can
proceed as chair of division two
of the house finance committee i find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12
and pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized
to meet electronically this public
meeting
is pertaining to hb1 and hb2
and amendments that we need to work on
today
please note that there is no fiscal
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with emergency
order one
i am confirming that all members of the
committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting
should email lba underscore
fiscal leg
state
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
lba staff are on the meeting assisting
us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote let's
start the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
representative petry would you please
uh representative turcotte for danielson
representative turcotte is uh in
barrington at my
house i am in my office alone
and uh i am uh same scenario my wife is
roaming around and the dog is still
roaming around
uh representative myrna for
representative lynn
i'm home and alone thank you
representative lay for representative
bucco
i am home in jaffrey and i am alone
thank you welcome representative heath
miry heath here in manchester and i too
am home alone
representative murray good morning kate
murray is here in newcastle with the dog
and david's in the basement
thank you all right very good
you caught me you caught me
yes uh representative amberger and i'm
in uh
kearsarge and my husband is in the house
sorry about that and welcome oh that's
okay
so um first of all
welcome everyone who is not normally on
division two we're glad to have you this
morning
what our procedures are is that we
basically mute ourselves
and if we have questions we raise our
hand
and then i will call on
people in the order that they have
raised their hands
most of the time sometimes i miss it but
everybody everybody that wants to say
something uh
has an opportunity to do that so
um mickey sent out some documents last
night
and i guess they overwhelmed my computer
okay everybody got them i'm
i'm going to be switching between the um
the website and um what mickey's doing
so if uh mickey if you could um
i think you've got this in a good order
and that we will um go forward
with the order that you have identified
so if we could please go ahead sure i
think i'm gonna ask andrea to share the
screen again
uh this worked pretty well uh in our
previous work sessions and i think
perhaps we start with the house bill 2
tracking document which is the
portrait there we go portrait oriented
schedule that shows everything that was
in house bill 2 assigned to us
as well as some new amendments proposed
as well as the division's
actions to date so representative murray
did you just want to go in order
just right through or is there anything
no i think we can just go in order and
if there are
um you know if they're questions or we
want to pass over something
we can do that and then um
we can figure out
at the end where we are okay and
so please and i think that it's a
logical
um a logical approach to uh
what we uh what we need to do today okay
so in that case the first uh section
of house bill 2 i would point to is on
page 22 sections 45 and 46
and this is relative to the calculation
of adequate education grants
if you recall the governor had
recommended
change for the biennium that would
essentially
lift up the free and reduced lunch adm
counts
um in recognition of the pandemic's
effect on
those counts being uh reported to the
department and
and use for calculating adequate
education grants for the next two years
um i have no amendments to make any
changes to this
and as you know the amounts appropriated
in the budget align with this uh
change in the estimates provided by the
department
mickey what is this called on the
website
so if you're on the website the i think
it's called hb2
tracking sheet okay
sorry down the first one or the second
one
the uh so there's uh hb there's a budget
tracking sheet and then um i think it's
like the third
uh black bullet down there's http
tracking sheet as of 324 21.
okay
and and which item are we looking at
excuse me uh page 22 sections 45 and 46.
okay uh seeing none um
could i have a motion to accept
sections 44 through 46
i moved thank you do i have a second
turquod seconds i believe i believe it's
40 sections 45 and 46 not 44 though
oh yeah i'm sorry 45 and 46 excuse me
thank you lin okay
um i had no discussion before so
is there anything that anyone wants to
say
seeing none would um the clerk
please call the role thank you madam
chair
representative turkite votes yes
uh representative uh let me
see here i'm sorry werner
yes thank you
representative lay yes
you're muted representative heath yes
heath votes yes sorry thank you
representative murray
murray votes yes thank you
uh representative umberger
representative umberger votes yes
affirmative okay
uh next one oops yeah the next one is uh
public school infrastructure transfer
yep so the next one is uh um relative to
sections 48 through 50 in house bill 2
and we have amendment 0957h
and this is the first amendment in the
house bill 2 amendment packet that was
sent
out thank you andrea so this amendment
essentially does
three things the first if you recall the
governor's budget
recommended transferring 15 million
dollars a year from the education trust
fund
to the public school infrastructure fund
this section and
this amendment in section 48 reduces
that amount to 1 million dollars for a
year
effectively freeing up 14 million a year
for other uses
the next item that this amendment
affects is
under current law the public school
at the end of this biennium fiscal 21
the governor's budget had kicked that
date out for two years
because of the recommendation of adding
more money to the fund this amendment if
you'll see online yeah line 17
that perspective repeal is repealed
therefore there is no
statutory end date to this fund
pursuant to this amendment so there
would be no deadline to expend the funds
or anything like that
and the last change right above that on
lines 13 through 16
is language that essentially says that
in order to be eligible for a grant a
school
it needs to be determined that the
school did not have
any federal stimulus dollars available
to it to meet the needs that they're
asking for
from the public school infrastructure
fund
this would be something the commission
in consultation with the department
grant
okay are there any questions on this
amendment
okay seeing none um
could i have a motion to
accept amendment
0 9 5 7 h
so moved to representative turcon
second okay thank you
is there any other discussion
seeing none representative petry would
thank you madam chair uh
representative turcotte representative
turcotte votes yes
yes
uh representative lay representative lay
votes yes
representative heath heath votes yes
representative murray very votes yes
representative umberger representative
umberger votes yes
thank you madam chair the vote is 7-0
any affirmative
okay so
mickey next uh so moving on the the
final set of sections in house bill 2
uh for this division to uh to deal with
is sections 116 to 120
relative to ccs and usnh uh
representative turcotte has
a an amendment redrafted from yesterday
zero nine eight six h
which begins on page three of your
amendment packet
um and i think i'll defer to
representative turcotte to
um walk everyone through the amendment
and the changes from yesterday
uh representative turcotte would you
please accomplish that
certainly um not a lot of huge changes
in it uh
only three to be specific otherwise it's
exactly the same as the one we reviewed
yesterday
uh the first change is uh
the date of april first
which was uh the date
that the commission shall recommend
legislation that
is now january 1st uh 2022.
the second change
is the makeup of the committee in
discussions
yesterday in our hearing we talked about
removing
the speaker of the house designee
and the president of the senate designee
in putting
those two positions uh appointments to
the governor so now
those two and the governor will make
three appointments and the
only other change is the funding for it
uh it was recommended
chairperson humburger recommended the
funding on that
and that's set at 1.5 million for the
okay is there any discussion on this
uh representative murray thank you madam
chair i just want to thank everybody for
the discussion yesterday it's really
hard to do amendments through emails
and it was really helpful at least for
me to have the
rather a broad ranging discussion
yesterday yesterday on some of these
issues
so i appreciate the discussion and
everybody's patience so thank you
representative heath adam chair thank
you um i'd like to take this opportunity
to to withdraw
our amendment and also thank
uh representative turcotte um we've had
good conversations
and we agree our purpose was to try and
and slow this process down a bit and i
think we've accomplished what we need to
do
so thank you all thank you
representative heath
i would really like to thank everybody
that has
worked on this and um representative
turcotte
in particular because sometimes it's uh
it's hard to put the words on the paper
it's easy to criticize and so um
i think that uh that we have uh
a good a good amendment and i think that
um we will uh will find this
uh to be the right way to go
so all right uh
could i have a motion on amendment
nine eight six zero nine eight six
key seconds thank you
okay will the clerk call the roll please
thank you ma'am chair uh representative
turcotte
uh representative turcotte votes yes
uh representative murder for lynn
representative bernard voceas
representative lay representative lay
votes yes
resume heath heath beauchess
representative murray very votes yes
representative representative umberger
votes yes
madam chair the vote is 7-0 in the
affirmative
thank you all very much and we have
we have worked very hard on this and i
and i appreciate it
resident turca you have your hand raised
yes thank you madam chair i i just want
to
uh seriously thank everybody who was
involved in this
uh they were as i said yesterday a lot
of competing
interests and i received a lot of input
a lot of discussion and i just want to
thank you for that comment it's it is so
true
okay um mickey what's next
so the next amendment we're going to go
down to the the subsection for new
sections
we've now taken votes on everything in
house bill 2 has introduced that it came
to the committee so that's a
that's a good accomplishment we're done
with that we do have
six there are five new house bill two
amendments still to discuss the first
being
uh zero nine nine uh assuming zero nine
eight eight
h relative to funding for the dual and
concurrent enrollment
program if you recall we've previously
adopted an amendment
um 0-8-5-2-h
to move the administration of the
program from doe
to ccsnh this appropriation
would provide one and a half million
dollars
per year to the community college system
to administer and fund this program
uh mickey before we do this i would like
to go
back to the um
we had moved that
down to 1 million each year and i'd like
to
discuss the items
that we're looking at in hb1
uh in in those dollars instead you know
before we uh
tackle them individually because it is
it's a
i guess i call it a package so
if we could do that i would uh i would
appreciate it
okay so andrea do you want to jump over
to the budget tracking
sheet for me is this the document here
okay so uh on row one
and also it appears or excuse me yeah
we'll stick with row one
so this is the reduction to the public
school infrastructure fund that we
already just approved with amendment
zero nine
five seven h so you'll see that 14
million dollars a year
uh reduction to that um
initiative that we approved in house
bill 2.
um do you want me to do these in order
do you want me to jump back to the dual
and concurrent
enrollment no just just do them in order
we'll
we'll we'll get through them all and
then go down and
do whatever we need in amendments if we
could okay
sure so so the um the next item on here
does not have a house bill to
appropriation this would be a house bill
1 section
or as house bill 1 change to the line
for a special education aid in the
department of education's budget
representative umberger has a proposal
to increase the aid
in this program to fund what is the
estimated full
um reimbursement without proration
for the the special education aid
program formerly known as the
catastrophic aid program
uh so andrea has the page up there
currently in the the budget as
introduced
there's 30.8 million dollars per year
you'll see the proposed
increase per year that would uh
hopefully
is there anyone that has a problem
okay seeing none um
i i guess i need a motion to
um increase
the special education fund
by five million five hundred and sixty
nine
do can i have a motion on that please he
would move that motion to increase the
amount by
um i'm five million was it five million
yeah five million yeah here thank you
and just just to clarify it would be the
exact amount on the
um the sheet that andrea has shared now
so two
2 million 452 in the first year and 3
million
117 in the second year for a total of
uh 5 million 569 just as we'll be
precise i just want to make sure it's
well
petry could you uh make the motion
please
uh um i got a question what uh
exactly so we're voting just on this uh
on these lines
that's correct okay
very good uh let me all right
i'll call a roll no you need you need to
make the motion
oh i'm sorry yes i thought mary made
motion
okay well
whatever you accept madam chair okay we
have
we have representative keith made the
motion is that correct
that is correct and rep representative
murray seconded
you can call the roll thank you madam
chair
uh representative forgot votes yes
president petrie votes yes
representative murder
uh representative yes representative
blake
representative lay votes yes
representative heath
info chess representative murray
murray votes yes representative berger
votes yes madam chair the vote is 7-0
permit
um
the next item here is uh
the startup grants for uh 20
for kindergarten and um
we had sent out uh sb
82 for everyone to look at
and as i understand it this was simply
whatever went on with getting the budget
approved
in
so this is to
um provide
the startup grants to several towns
that um were expecting that money
in the last budget which did not occur
for you know whatever reason
okay seeing none can i have a motion
please
do i have a second turret got second
thank you very much
uh mr clerk you can call the role
the command of chair uh representative
turcotte
uh representative turcotte yes represent
petri votes yes
representative uh werner
uh represented myrna yes representative
lay
representative lay votes yes
representative heath
heath beauchess representative murray
murray votes yes representative
romberger
representative bomberger votes yes i am
chair of the voter 7-0 affirmative
thank you all very much
okay um
the next item down is oh we're spending
money that we don't have but that's okay
transfer of
[Music]
million dollars to the general fund
and um this is so
that uh we can
fund the items that are in the
next group is that correct mickey
that's correct so um based on all the
items that you do have before you today
this would be the transfer required to
essentially
so as you can see there's a lot of
general fund
expenditures proposed or increases
proposed but all the reductions made
were in the education trust fund so it's
are there any questions on this
okay seeing none could i have a motion
to transfer is it twenty two thousand
twenty two million seven hundred
thousand dollars
from the education trust fund to the
president moves out
uh representative murder will second it
okay um representative petry would you
please call the roll
thank you madam chair uh representative
representative votes yes president
petrie votes yes
representative mirner representative
mirna yes
representative lay representative lay
votes yes
president heath heath vote yes
representative murray
murray votes yes representative umberger
representative umberger votes yes madam
chair the vote is
7-0 any affirmative okay
uh although i didn't um
identify the amendment numbers
this vote verifies that those amendments
have passed
so i want to make sure that we have
an understanding of that okay
uh the next item on the uh
as we move down this page
is uh funding for the three
lab positions
commissioner quinn's top priorities to
get
funded and uh representative heath i
think you had something
um madam chair um we did identify
i believe um the the two in the criminal
lab
or the um forensic lab i guess it's
called
okay and then one would be
um oh mickey help me i'm forgetting what
the
uh the position is so
andrea has the uh the chain sheet there
so these three positions are scattered
across three different accounting units
so one's in the uh the urine codis lab
one is in the
toxicology lab and one's in the forensic
lab as far as budgeting purposes
so you can see those on your screen
right now and
down at the very bottom is where you'll
see the subtotal and i do just want to
point out that this
change does have two rows on that
previous sheet so there is a
general fund impact and a highway fund
impact just because of the nature of
thank you representative don't feel bad
i knew they were someplace in uh in
there but you know what
mickey always always takes care of us so
won't we thank goodness for mickey yes
isn't that the truth
could i have a motion to
so moved okay
uh representative petry was that you
also talking
yes yes ma'am okay oh i'll second that
i'll put
i'll um i think she beat me
okay
thank you um representative petrie would
you please call the roll
representative turcotte uh
representative turcotte votes yes
representative petry votes yes
representative uh
myrna representative berna yes
representative lay representative lay
votes yes
representative heath heath votes yes
representative murray
murray votes yes and representative
umberger
representative umberger votes yes madam
chair the vote is 7-0
any affirmative thank you very much
9086 did that take care of this
it did so that that appropriation will
be a house bill two appropriations so
this
uh this line is already taken care of
dual and concurrent enrollment
um this is amendment uh
zero nine eight eight h
and i am proposing
that we put 1.5
million dollars into this program for
each year
i don't know whether this is the right
number or not but i think this is
a high number
but i'm willing to um i'm willing to
support that
and uh
mickey in the amendment did we indicate
that um ccsnh could use
this for administrative costs if
necessary
uh yes the the amendment does say for
the purpose of funding and administering
the program
okay thank you representative heath
madame chair i want to thank you um i
thank you you've
all probably seen the email that we
received from
um the chancellor heward from the um
community college system this is one of
the most successful programs it serves
over 6 000 students
and i am thrilled that we will um
budget 1.5 million in each year thank
you very much
was that a was that a motion yes it was
i look like that we approve
amendment zero nine eight eight eight
eight
okay thank you very much checking that
uh seeing none will the clerk call the
rule please
oh thank you madam chair uh
representative turcotte
uh representative tarkov chess votes yes
uh representative murder representative
murder yes
representative lay representative lay
votes yes
representative heath heath beauchamp
representative murray voces
representative allenberger
representative umberger votes yes
uh madam chair the vote is 7-0 in the
affirmative
uh thank you very much
uh the next item is
um fund the robotics program
at the current time there is no money in
and
you heard me say yesterday that uh dual
and concurrent enrollment
is a program that i really like
and i believe that the robotics program
for the high schools uh falls into that
into that same category i know we had
not talked about it
um i but i i hope
that we can get
agreement that the robotics program
is essential to our
our students within the state
so are there any comments or
discussion uh
representative heath um madam chair
i just want to comment on how effective
a program it's been
over the years i remember when dean came
in landed his helicopter
in uh gill stadium many many years ago
and i'm pleased to be able to support
this
amendment thank you thank you was that
a motion to accept it was indeed
okay thank you do i have a second please
american second all right thank you very
much
are there any further comments
seeing none representative petrie would
you call the rule
thank you madam chair madam um you know
madame turcotte
representative tour got votes here
president petra goats yes
representative mirner representative
myrna yes
representative lay representative lay
votes yes
representative heath heath beauchess
representative murray
murray vocias representative von berger
representative umberger votes yes madam
okay
the next item is to
okay mickey yes
do we have an amendment to
um continue to keep the line
for ccsnh and unh separate
uh we do and we'll get so we've got if
you want to stick to the order of this
sheet we have the student data system
and then the next item does do that
oh okay
okay do you want to come to that now or
do you want to do this
no no we'll do the uh student
information data system
software costs it's not really software
cost it's
operational costs i guess but that's
okay call it what we want
um we had initially
i think right voted to take this money
out
or we just were not supportive of it
it's not currently in the governor's
recommended budget and at first
there were really no amendments to add
the money
but we had a recent discussion with the
department on monday
and so their first their initial uh
we're able to modify that to one and a
okay are there any comments
on this comments or questions from
anyone
uh madam chair of rap charcot yes go
ahead
yeah um i will
unfortunately i think i'll have to vote
no on this not so much that i don't
think it's needed i just simply
uh being parachuted onto this committee
recently it's just something i don't
know enough
about to vote in the affirmative it's so
just so everybody knows it's not that i
don't want it or
i just don't know enough about it so i
want to get that out there
okay thank you are there any other
okay seeing none um
could i have a motion to
put 1.5 million in
22 and 23 into the
costs
don't all talk at once
okay i don't seem to have a motion on
that so we will
okay the next item is to increase the
funding
for the community college and us
so we do have a detailed change sheet
for this item and
okay can she have that up and she can
there we go so currently in the
governor's recommended budget
uh agency number 78 is established as
the
collet community college and university
system this motion here
would break the college the community
college system and the university system
back to their own separate
agency code in the operating budget as
well as
fund um usnh at 88.5 million dollars per
year
and the community college system at 56
okay and this this all okay so you said
this
um
so we should we sh the motion on the
floor i guess should be
approve zero not zero nine
oh we did that yeah we've done we've
done uh
zero nine so this really is just a house
bill one
change and that's that change sheet
that's on the screen right now
so these all these would just be uh
appropriations
in the budget document itself not we've
we've already kind of affected
this with e2 with the representative
amendment and this would essentially
line up the with that amendment as well
as
change the funding levels for uh over
the biennium increase by 11 million
dollars
okay representative heath thank you
madam chair
madam chair if i understand correctly
that this um amendment
would level fund both institutions
and continue to keep their budget
separate
is that correct madam chair uh that's
certainly my understanding of what what
this
what zero yeah zero nine eight nine did
and then here we're actually putting
that money into hb1
thank you madam chair i would so move
that amendment
okay murray will second all right
so what we're doing is increasing
funding to ccs and h
and u.s nh
okay um representative petry would you
please call the role
the command of chair uh representative
turcotte
representative turcotte votes no
president petrie votes yes
representative mirner
yes representatives representative lay
representative lay votes yes
representative heath heath
beauchess representative murray murray
votes yes
representative murder amberger votes yes
madam chair the vote is six to one in
in the affirmative thank you all very
much
we do have a couple highway fund related
house bill 1 items
so the three lab positions we've already
approved that
on row 12 of the tracking document the
next item we have
um relates to winter maintenance so as
you recall
our highway fund position at this point
through all the actions taken is about
uh
1.6 million dollars um in the deficit
from from our target of balancing so
this item here
to reduce winter maintenance would uh
result in a
balanced highway fund budget out of
division two
and this was a line that had been
previously discussed
in a work session to um to change to do
so
is there any are there any questions
comments and care
yes please um mickey could you clarify
that again um what is the impact
so in the uh in the budget right now um
winter maintenance is kind of funded at
a pretty healthy level compared to
previous budgets
yes this um item here would reduce
winter maintenance appropriations by 875
a year of highway fund appropriations uh
as before you consider this action the
highway fund right now
budget and division two is in deficit by
about 1.6 million dollars
this was the approach that was discussed
earlier in division
as an area to take a reduction to be
able to balance the highway fund
the department of transportation has the
authority statutorily
and has exercised it many times before
to be able to come to fiscal
if winters are bad and they do need
additional funds above what's budgeted
um that was also part of the discuss the
discussion
on why this would be an area to
potentially reduce
thank you mickey are there any further
questions
one uh one of the things that we have to
do
no matter what is balance all of our um
trust funds oh they're not trust funds
or whatever the highway fund
the uh fishing game etc so
um this was our way
of accomplishing that for the highway
fund and
hopefully everyone can support this
unless
mary's money tree has
a million six in it
right representative murray
thank you very much um can we just uh
reconfirm
that um transportation is fine with us
doing this
and let's pray we don't get another
uh yes transportation is
okay with this obviously
obviously they would like us not to do
this
but on the other hand i think it's um
it's important that they understand
and know that they can they can go
okay um is there anything else that
anyone has
representative turcotte moves the motion
as proposed
oh second american second all right
thank you very much
representative petry would you please
call the role
thank you manager uh representative
turcotte
uh representative turk i vote yes
president petry volch yes
representative berner representative
murder vote yes
representative delay representative lay
votes yes
representative heath heath votes yes
representative murray
murray votes yes representative uh
umberger
representative umberger votes yes madam
chair the vote is 7-0 any affirmative
okay um we do have one final house bill
one amendment to consider
representative heath has an amendment
that would
uh essentially move two million dollars
per year from the winter maintenance
accounting unit at the department of
safety
to mechanical services for the purpose
of purchasing fleet equipment
um both of these uh
it should just be noted we just took an
action on winter maintenance
if this were to be approved too i just
wanted to be clear that they would both
be um
it'd be an incremental change it
wouldn't this this action wouldn't over
write what we just did so i would i
would add the uh the sum of both of
these actions when we when we form the
budget for you
as you'll notice on the winter
maintenance account presentation on the
screen now
it has the same beginning and revise you
know so it's not updated for the action
together
representative heath um thank you madam
chair um we hope
that you'll consider this amendment we
know that the
um line item for uh
winter for the equipment maintenance has
been
um greatly reduced and this would not
fix it but it would at least help out a
little bit
and we'd like to do that for d.o.t
um uh
i would i would like to say this oh
represent turcotte please go ahead
ways and means was able to find some
additional money and
i shouldn't say fine i mean the revenues
have been coming in uh
gangbusters and
position i would like to
see that money some of that money
used to support
the equipment requirements
and not take any additional out of
winter maintenance because
our forecast for
um road toll
and turnpike toll are
not that rosy for the next
two years i mean i realize we can go
that safety safety the transportation
can go
to um fiscal
but if there's no money there then it
becomes
a little difficult for fiscal
to approve uh
winter maintenance money so that's
that's my
my thought um and
uh i'll let let's see representative
turcotte i believe you
um i'm all set for now i don't think
okay representative heath so madam chair
based on what you just said you said
that there are additional funds
coming out of ways and means and you
would be willing
to take two million of that funding
to put into the line
of equi building
yeah equipment maintenance
and actually that would do
what we had proposed to do so am i
i i'm sorry my question is are you
you said you the additional funding was
identified in ways and means
and you would be willing to take two
million
of that funding for each year of the
biennium
yes what's the problem and i would
withdraw my amendment madam chair
and i would go with what you have
recommended thank you okay
no i think that was fine with me i was
just going to ask if we had already
moved the 2 million out of winter
maintenance
wouldn't that have been the two million
that we put into mechanical services
but um i support if you're support what
you were doing if we can get the money
from ways and means then
let's do that thank you well i
i hope so i'll put it that way okay
that concludes house bill 1 amendments
we have if we jump back over to the
house bill 2
tracker we still have two two amendments
to consider that do not have a
money impact to them on the state budget
one is the representative weiler
amendment relative to the school
planning committee vacancies
and the other is relative to the charter
school lease
aid cap from five house bill 521.
we discussed both of these yesterday
amendments
as uh oh uh representative turcotte
yes thank you madam chair um on the
weiler amendment
i was under the impression that uh
representative weiler
might come on and actually explain what
his
uh amendment meant because i
i don't think most of us under
understood it i know i didn't
i concur wholeheartedly
and i asked him to try to be with us
at 11. uh mickey is he out there yet
i don't see him here we can do
the other amendment uh what's the number
here
uh 0 894 and maybe he'll show up here in
the next couple minutes to discuss
his amendment uh could you give him a
call i think he's in his office
if we could um zero
eight nine four h okay
um this amendment
doesn't cost us any money it is
simply allowing
the charter schools
lease payments of 50 000 or
50 thousand dollars this does not neces
there's no more money associated with
this
it's just that um when
the money when the requests come in
to doe then uh they will be
prorated like a lot of other things
within the um within the budget
or within education
so that's um that's why
we are um that's why i'm putting this
amendment in
just to allow i have no idea what
um what the lease costs are broken down
by
um particular charter schools all this
does
is if their lease cost is
between 30 and 50 000 that they can
apply for the the money to
um to fund it doesn't mean they're going
to get it
it just means that that is now the
upper limit so are there any
could i have a motion to approve
amendment
zero nine zero eight nine four
so moved thank you
when you're ready representative petry
would you call the role please
thank you man uh representative
representative turcotte
representative peter gaulties
representative
mirner representative merna vocchies
representative representative lay votes
no
representative heath youth votes no
representative murray very votes no
representative about murder
representative umberger votes yes
madam chair the vote is four three the
motion passes
uh thank you very much okay
uh mickey next
i think that's all we have except for
the weiler amendment and um
my understanding is he may be on the
road home from the state house so i
i we're trying to track him down to
confirm that but i
okay well then i think we'll
i think we're we need repres okay
representative heath
oh thank you madam chair madam chair um
what about the
scholarships are we all set did we cover
that
area the unique program
and um yes we did
we're all set thank you very much i
don't remember what the amendment was
but uh we had it thank you
we still have some um
cleanup work to do and uh
several other votes that we need to
we need to take and we
promised representative lynn
that he could talk to us tomorrow
morning about the uh
about the court case so
um what i would like to do
is to um recess
this session until
10 o'clock tomorrow morning and
that's one amendment from uh
representative weiler and uh things like
mickey needs the authority to
make adjustments you know whatever
and to make sure that we're doing all
the right things
um and what else mickey do you need do
we need to
like
excuse me we need to vote on each
individual's
each individual um
budget is that correct we can or we can
do a block vote
for you know the agencies that we have
in division two and just do a block vote
that we're going to accept those budgets
as previously
amended through the changes we've
adopted so
we can do something formal just to kind
of close out everything once where
once we know we're done our work
okay so is 10 o'clock tomorrow
it um it may not it probably won't be
more than um
half an hour to get all this stuff done
so
uh representative murray
yeah thank you um on monday there's the
presentation the divisions will be do
presentations
to the full finance committee is in my
calendar
well and my well my i have i have my
second kovitz shot on monday afternoon
so um i'm just wondering how that fits
in because i had that in my calendar i'm
wondering
um it doesn't we're not voting on that
so it doesn't seem like i need to sub
or do am i going to need to sub for
whatever we do on monday
we're not having anything on monday okay
if i if i understood correctly
tuesday is the uh
excuse me is full finance to
uh discuss the budget at
is that right mickey
don't shake ahead i honestly don't know
i know
uh as of about 10 o'clock this morning i
know there was uh
they were still trying to work the
schedule because we do have a lot of
bills to exec
as well i think there's ten ten bills
the committee has to execute two before
our deadline in addition to house bill
one and two
so um i think most of except for one is
retained anyways but we still have to
formally
do that as a full committee so i think
janet was still scheduling
um next week last i heard so i haven't
seen
any fixed dates or times okay do we need
to retain do we need a motion to retain
sb 82 how do we dispose of that no well
we haven't we haven't
officially started work on that in divi
in house finance yet that bill's been
referred to us but we still have to have
a public hearing on it before it even
comes to division
at some point since we adopted the
amendment with the language from
senate bill 82 into house bill 2 uh
you'd probably just want to retain that
bill
when it does eventually make its way to
us but um i think we're still
a little early on senate bill 182
because we still have to have a public
hearing
okay so that that one you won't have to
worry about for crossover that'll be a
post crossover bill we deal with okay
i see that janet has janet clayman has
you could bring her up and she'll have
hi janet here i am
i was just listening to you talk about
monday and it's my understanding right
now i'm still waiting for confirmation
from representative weiler but
it looks like monday is going to be
um monday morning would be when you
could work
on your all those retain bills that you
still need to exec
out and you've got one that is uh
house bill 600 from division three which
that one
came out ought to pass as amended but
every all the other bills are retained
um and then it looks like the after late
june
just a minute just a minute 600
you said that was division two no three
house bills oh
okay house bill 600 division three yeah
okay
uh no no no don't worry you don't have
um but i'm told like so then that would
be monday morning and then monday
afternoon you'd go into
um talking about house bill 1 and house
bill 2. that would be the
like the briefing by the divisions to
the full
bull committee and then tuesday looks
like it would be a work day for
lba and ols to work on developing the
the combined budget amendments and then
um what i have is in wednesday the 31st
would be the continued exec
session on house bill 1 and house bill
2. so like i said i'm right now i'm
waiting for confirmation from
from representative weiler um i j and i
did just try to call him
about the amendment he has envisioned
two but
he didn't pick up his phone and his his
um his mailbox is full
so i couldn't leave him a message yes i
i tried that as well did you
yeah yeah so as i was just
i was just sending him an email when i
heard you discussing not having to work
on monday but i think
it looks like that's because that
suggestion was sent to
um aaron and the speaker and he
he approved i think he thought that
scheduling was fine
so okay so that's a change from
yesterday yeah but i like i said i
haven't heard i just i kind of before i
put anything in the calendar i'd really
like to have representative weiler say
yes this is what we're doing you know i
don't wanna just presume that i'm
gonna just schedule people so
okay so so monday and wednesday
yes correct will there be mo
voting on monday do i need to worry
about a sub or will there be any
is monday a listening day or a voting
day
i think it's from what from my notes
that i have from
uh mr kane it looks like it's just
it's just briefing like it doesn't look
like there's any voting but i
i that i i don't know i mean i can't
i can't confirm that um
uh well actually hang on because it does
say
um the divisions will present the
recommendations
recommendations to the full committee
lbas then directed to draft the official
amendments for
house bill one and two um for committee
vote
so i guess that would mean that you
would be voting on certain things
and then giving it to the lba what do
you think
yeah usually sorry usually what we do is
each division will present their budget
package the house bill one changes in
the division two or house bill two
amendments
and the committee will vote to adopt
those amendments so we'll go around and
adopt house bill one
and two for division one same for
division two division three
then our office will go back and
actually string everything together to
be
basically one house bill two on one host
for one and then that's the official
vote on
um wednesday in this case so there
probably would be
would that be finished in the morning
my my shot isn't until the afternoon so
i'm wondering
um by the sounds of it janet
is that the plan for the afternoon is to
get into house bill one and two and
monday morning would be on the other
bills correct
yeah yeah and i don't know how long
it'll take to do those 10 bills i mean
they were all retained except for one
but
that's not my you know i don't know so
um
when i spoke with mr kane he said yeah
you'd have to start at nine o'clock on
monday morning and take care of all the
the bills that are in your possession
and then move on to house bill one and
house bill two
so i don't think there's anything
controversial in the bills that have
been retained
right so maybe you could move into house
bill one hospital two
at ten o'clock in the morning i mean i
you know if it only takes about an hour
to take care of those
retain bills the roll calls will be the
most time consuming
okay so uh
i guess kate representative murray the
answer to that is that
um you might want to um
have somebody or or you talk to mary
jane
and see what um see what her preference
is on that it's you know
in division you know i would have told
you yes go ahead and get a sum
but i don't i can't speak for
how when you don't know how long it's
taken
i'm fine in the morning but my shots you
know two o'clock in the afternoon and
we do not give up our shots do we
absolutely not
all right we'll discuss that and we'll
certainly let you know whether or not i
need a sub
uh thank you janet thank you so much uh
that
yeah that's okay i guess uh we'll all
flip a coin
uh to the
to the best of my knowledge um
those sessions are going to not
so if um i don't know
i'll try to get some clarification
before tomorrow
um i'll
i'll send another email out and
see if representative weiler reads his
email so
okay representative heath well thank you
ma'am cheer um
just i wanted to make sure that on those
sessions they
may not be virtual or are they going to
be
um kind of a hybrid
i think okay and that's just me
that they will be hybrid but i'm not
i'm not positive i don't know that um
that decision has been made by
representative wyler
i just i don't know thank you man
yeah but if they if they are hybrid
they the finance committee will meet in
reps hall and
so that will be um you know fully spaced
out
and all of that so it would
i would hope that if you can
that you would attend only so that i can
actually say
instead of through this zoom stuff
so but uh anyhow i guess we'll uh
no uh representative lay are you going
to be with us tomorrow
no i don't think so no no okay
representative bucco is coming back
tomorrow oh okay great
yeah and representative murder i know
that you will not be with us tomorrow
morning
because uh representative lin has
promised us
a briefing on
the uh on the court case
so um thank you very much both of you
for
uh for being here uh with us
so i think we'll recess until
tomorrow morning at 10 o'clock
and hopefully we can finish up all of
our work
then thank you okay thank you
have a good afternoon thank you y'all
take care
mickey mickey
thanks